Imagine you're
walking in the forest
and you encounter an object.
What questions come
through your mind?
First of all, what if this?
Is this a stick?
Obviously it's a stick.
Secondly, hmm, what
can I do with it?
If you are a child like
this little fellow,
poking somebody with it may
sound like a great idea.
Or if you're older,
you can probably
use the stick as a walking aid.
Find some more
sticks and maybe you
can use them to build a shelter.
Or you can use them to keep
warm on cold winter nights.
The stick is an
example of an entity.
And the many uses of it
are called affordances.
This video is about
schema.org actions.
And you can think of them as
entities plus affordances.
What's so exciting
about actions?
I think that actions can
enable some of the experiences
I only read about in science
fiction books growing up.
But let's start
at the beginning.
Hi, I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz.
If you watched the previous
two videos in this series,
you know that my DJ buddy
Shawn and I built a system
to make the data
from our music store
machine readable and available
in the Knowledge Graph.
We use schema.org and JSON-LD
so that when the user says,
OK Google, and asks to listen
to a music artist we carry,
our mobile application
will be ready to fulfill
users' requests.
Shawn and I published
the information
about the artists we
carry in our store.
We used JSON-LD
markup and embedded it
in artist web pages on our site.
We associated our mobile
music app with the artists
we carry so that our app could
be triggered by the OK Google
voice command.
Remember my story
about the stick?
As I told you earlier, the
many useful and not so useful
things that can be done with
it are called affordances.
And the affordance
is the quality
of an object, or an
environment, which
allows an individual
to perform an action.
What does this have to do
with schema.org actions?
Let me explain.
If you take a look at
this JSON-LD markup,
you will notice that the
potentialAction property
identifies a
ListenAction affordance.
This means that the music
artist from our store
can be listened to
using our mobile app.
Let's revisit this simple
architecture diagram
from our first video.
The JSON-LD markup
from our store site
is processed by a
crawler and then saved
in our small Knowledge Graph
running in an open source graph
database called Cayley.
The crawler parses the
markup from our site
and transforms it into triples.
Triples are data representation
well-suited for graphs.
Once we have the triples, we
can load them into Cayley.
As you can see in
this visualization,
green nodes represent
the potentialAction.
Much like other structured data
about our music store entities,
we have loaded the
potentialAction triples
into Cayley.
We have also loaded a music
data set from Freebase.
Now, Cayley can answer
handy questions such as,
how can I listen to Nerdcore?
As you can see, the query
produces an Android app
as the result.
The app can be invoked to
play the music we want.
To show you how
this all works, we
will use our Android action
simulator and our sample music
app.
Let's try to listen to Nerdcore.
With the simulator, we can
issue the query for the genre.
The full query
expression sent to Cayley
is similar to the one
I showed you earlier.
This should trigger
our sample music app.
Oops!
Or maybe not.
Why isn't this working?
Let's look at the
AndroidManifest
of our sample music app.
Oh, we forgot to include
the intent filter.
We may need to fix that.
MEDIA_PLAY_FROM_SEARCH handling
was missing from our manifest.
Now we can try again.
Sure enough, the
music starts playing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
So far, we've covered how a
mobile app can be triggered
in our response to
a voice command,
and I showed you the JSON-LD
markup which enables this.
What about the web?
Schema.org actions allows us
to specify web actions as well.
For example, similarly
to the mobile app,
we can indicate that the
artist from our store
can be listened to on the web.
Note that the HTTP
link identifies
the URL where the user
can listen to the artist.
Besides the ListenAction, what
other types of affordances
can we specify using schema.org?
A lot of them.
Not all of them apply
to all entities, though.
For example,
ListenAction may not
work very well with a stick.
OK, let's look at
another affordance
called the SearchAction.
To illustrate how the
SearchAction works,
we will use our web simulator
to help us invoke actions.
Let's fire it up.
All right, let's point the
simulator at our music site.
As you can tell, the
simulator detected
we have a SearchAction
available.
How did it do that?
It's quite simple.
As you may have
guessed by now, we
used schema.org actions markup
on the main page of our store.
Here's what the
markup looks like.
Let's highlight a few things.
The potentialAction target
is the HTTP urlTemplate.
Remember that in
the mobile example,
we were using an
Android deep link.
The urlTemplate is
defined by RFC 6570.
And while that's a
very awesome spec,
we won't get into
the details here.
Suffice it to say, that the
query parameter is properly
substituted by the client, or,
in our case, the simulator.
Let's now invoke
the SearchAction.
As expected, we found Dual Core.
Since the simulator also
detected the ListenAction
in the JSON-LD response,
we can invoke it.
This takes us to our
jarekandshawnmusic.com site
where users can
listen to Dual Core.
The target URL
the simulator uses
is defined in the
JSON-LD response.
Now, we can hit the
Play button and enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Let's think about the search
use case for a second.
We use schema.org actions to
describe the search endpoint.
The simulator sent
the GET request
to the URL defined by our
markup with a query expression.
Note that we have associated
a RESTful API affordance
with an entity serialized
as a JSON-LD document.
This is an example
of a Hypermedia API.
The Hypermedia API topic is
quite fascinating in itself,
but we won't get into it today.
If you would like to learn
more about Hypermedia APIs,
click the link on your screen.
As you can tell by now,
schema.org action spec
is quite expressive,
and I have barely
scratched the surface
in this video.
I am very excited
about the potential
of schema.org actions.
I think it's a
step towards making
the dream I shared with you
in the first video a reality.
OK, what do we do next?
Let's learn more and
clone the repository
that we have shared
to try it out.
You can also get
more information from
developers.google.com/schemas.
Last but not least, if you find
this technology interesting,
please let me know.
I would love to hear from you.
Thanks and have a great day.